[Musik]
was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja leute wahrscheinlich wir
uns schon wieder meiner stimme ich habe
mich jetzt einfach innerhalb von drei
wochen zweimal erkältet also ich war
letztens wieder gesund jetzt habe ich
wieder deswegen heute ein eher
entspanntes video einfach hier vor
meinem schreibtisch aus ich hoffe ihr
versteht also diese woche kommen aber
auf jeden fall auch noch aufwändigere
videos zum beispiel der dritte teil von
iphone hoch tauschen die büroklammer
hoch tauschen
trotzdem denke ich dass dieses video
auch extrem cool wird oder zumindest die
videos die dann darauf folgen werden und
zwar habe ich mir letztens englische
videos angesehen und da haben viele
youtube ein video dazu gemacht wie sie
halt prominente leute bezahlt haben dass
sie irgendwas sagen was sie denn
vorgeben herzlich erstmal total dumm an
und ich hab mir so was gibt es in
deutschland ja gar nicht wer irgendwie
auch witzig weil ich halt direkt selber
dazu ein video machen können ich habe
mir jetzt letztens eine seite gefunden
wo das anscheinend wirklich gehen soll
mit irgendwelchen deutschen prominenten
darunter sogar youtuber also eigentlich
ganz einfach also ich hab euch das ganze
jetzt hier mal eingeblendet wir haben
hier die seite grizzly ja das ist glaube
ich nicht mal unbedingt ein deutscher
seite aber da sind auch deutsche
prominente angemeldet und das konzept
hinter dieser seite ist halt man kann
hingehen und sein idol suchen dann muss
man irgendwie geld bezahlen kann aber so
eine nachricht eintippen und dann wird
einfach genau das gesagt was du halt
vorgegeben hast und hier gibt es
wirklich eine menge deutsche leute zum
beispiel hans sarpei ehemaliger
fußballspieler genauso wie tim wiese
micaela schäfer erotik sternchen wir
haben in 2 21 ist ein youtuber melina
sophie ist auch hier angemeldet genau
hier also wirklich jede menge leute und
ich fand das so interessant und habe mir
gedacht wenn ich jetzt 20 euro bezahlen
oder 30 euro setzt sich dann
irgendjemand von den morgen dahin und
sagt genau das was ich halt vor gegeben
habe und schickt mir das von per
nachricht zu also mein ziel ist es
eigentlich alle sind finde ich auch lust
sich frank rosin da kann glaube ich ganz
gut kochen also mein ziel ist es ja so
ein bisschen meine freude zu verarschen
in dem ich den sagen junge abgehörten
nachricht bekommen
auf dich bezogen hier von keiner
tim wiese zum beispiel ein buch ich bin
mal gespannt wie teuer das am ende wird
ich wollte zwei oder drei auswählen
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt mal an
wenn ihr die idee aus so fährt wie ich
dann lass dir auf jeden fall jetzt schon
mal ein fed noch nach oben da und ich
glaube wir fangen einfach mal hier mit
der micaela von der wollte ich immer
schon so ein privates video hier kannst
du deinen grußtext eingeben bis zu 250
zeichen und ja das ist ganz so viel so
ich hab mir jetzt folge ist verlegt das
ganze natürlich überhaupt nicht ernst
nehmen das soll nur zum spaß sein ich
werde nur eine lustige reaktion haben
und zwar haben wir hier die micaela
schäfer sie ist ja mutig sonst war es
meine freundin die marie die models ja
nebenbei so ein bisschen und ich habe
mir gedacht ich schreibe micaela jetzt
mal ein text oder sie sollen im text
sagen dass sie meine freundin dazu
natürlich wird das nicht passieren das
kann ich mir jetzt auch schon sagen dass
sie halt meine freundin dazu überreden
möchte praktisch von der erotikbranche
zu überzeugen
ja und da lasse ich mir jetzt mal einen
schönen text einfach so jetzt habe ich
mir nämlich einen guten text einen
verlassen und zwar hallo michael also
bitte sagt folgenden text hallo marie
ich habe auf instagram gesehen dass du
gerne model ist tolle bilder
katja ist langsam auf wir brauchen neue
sternchen am erotik himmel
hast du interesse hast du interesse
beste grüße also wie schon gesagt das
ganze ist natürlich überhaupt nicht
ernst gemeint ich möchte halt nur dass
dann marie zeigen und sie denkt sich so
etwas woher sie denn jetzt von mir so
deswegen gebe ich jetzt mal meinen
nachnamen ein und vorn haben und meine
e-mail und jetzt habe ich keinen plan
wie es weitergeht hol dir dein video so
jetzt habe ich mich gerade angemeldet
geld ja video
ach so jetzt ist die frage jetzt wird
glaube ich wird kann ich hier zum
beispiel keine ahnung das sind zwei
sätze wenn du das für 30 euro mafia
nicht jetzt also mehr finde ich auch
keinen fall angebracht deswegen schlage
ich erst mal 25 euro inklusive tax sind
wir bei 30 euro vor kommen noch einmal
30 raus eine werbe und hab ich mir auf
diesem video und dann haben wir das
wieder drin war es das video wird eben
nicht zehn minuten
und wir machen weiter ist auf jeden fall
eine relativ teure video den er so wir
haben jetzt hier wie ich hab das jetzt
schon bezahlt oder was so ich habe jetzt
gerade 35 eur 70 für die micaela hier
bezahlt ob ich das geld jetzt jemals
wieder sehen werde oder nicht
ich hoffe mal schon wenn ich gibt es
ärger und wir schauen jetzt mal weiter
ich habe nämlich noch eine gute idee und
zwar würde ich hier ist einfach nur den
in scope nehmen weil ich glaube dass ist
so der bekannteste youtuber der hier
unterwegs ist gehen wir mal drauf und
zwar habe ich ja auch eine richtig gute
idee für mein mitbewohner im juli so wie
ich schreibe jetzt einmal bei nico es
wäre super wenn du folgendes sagen
könnten keine vorgeschichte und zwar
haben wir hier oben so nachbarn die
beschweren sich in letzter zeit immer
bei jurij immer laut musik machen und
ich tue jetzt so als hätten die nachbarn
dem in strip gesagt dass im juli maximal
und musik hört oder das in skopje jetzt
juli auffordern soll die musik leiser zu
machen in zukunft stelle ich mir ganz
lustig vor wenn ich ihnen das video
zeige also wir schreiben jetzt einfach
mal folgendes seine nachbarn von homer
folgender text
es wäre super wenn du folgendes sagen
können dass deine nachbarn von oben
meinte zu mir du hast immer so laut
musik absolute frechheit das geht gar
nicht macht die scheiße in zukunft
leiser
sonst gibt es stress get your video ich
bin ich mal gespannt er kommt im in
scott biete ich dafür 20 euro eigentlich
müsste das mehr sind als bei den kielern
ich will ja erst mal abwarten ob da
überhaupt irgendwas zurückkommt deswegen
halten wir das jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen gering 20 euro für so ein
kurzes video
ich meine wer wird es nicht machen und
ich zahle den bus eben hier natürlich
schon wieder sie haben 23 eur 80 bezahlt
ich habe jetzt gerade auch schon hier
genau der ist da wirklich sogar richtig
angemeldet in skopje trieb und kommen
was ich mich jetzt gerade nur frage die
schreiben es hier
wenn es nicht funktioniert kein großer
keinen grund zur sorge du kannst es dann
nochmal versuchen
und nun anderes idol fragen gut was
jetzt noch steht wichtig zu sagen du
zahlst nicht für nicht beantwortete
anfragen also mein geld komme ich mal
kurz auf das jetzt von weg ist kann ich
mir nämlich gut vorstellen hier gut
wurde noch nicht abgebucht
wir warten jetzt einfach mal wenn das
jetzt wirklich klappen sollte und ich
morgen oder übermorgen das video bekomme
dann mache ich das auf jeden fall öfter
und schreibt noch andere
dann aber zeigt die beiden videos dann
natürlich auch erstmal marie und juri
ich habe überlegt ob ich dem wie sie
jetzt auch noch direkt anfragen aber das
mache ich dann in nächst also leute wenn
ihr die idee feiert dann das auf jeden
fall noch nach oben da ich würde das
video jetzt erst mal so hoch laden heute
und dann gibt es halt am wochenende die
auflösung dazu ich würde sagen das
wasser erst mal das video heute ein
bisschen kürzer sorry ich bin krank ist
bin ich übermorgen gibt es dann
wahrscheinlich ein neues video wenn ich
wieder ein bisschen fitter bin heute
jetzt richtig gut wir sind uns dann
morgen wieder direkt auf jeden fall
instagram und snapshot ab und vielleicht
findet man mich ja auch irgendwann bei
goal.com
ich mache es auch in szene